with a bit of self-reflection I have
noticed a trend in my recent videos I
don't know if anybody else noticed this
but I have a very frequent use of the
word um so um I decided that I would
actually try to keep that lower tiny bit
I'm sorry if you didn't notice it and
that because of me saying this you're
probably gonna notice this in all of my
videos and not be able to pay attention
to anything else at least that's how it
kind of goes with me but and this is
just a tiny bit of self-reflection in
any case in this episode I'll mainly be
doing very standard foliage work since
that was really something that had to be
done and of course a tiny bit of fixing
up the station a tiny bit I think some
extra things because it wasn't entirely
finished and that as many it's also I
also I always have different soundtracks
for whenever I'm actually recording this
which is I suppose a little funny facts
actually throw out there I feel like I
can't commentates
to the for like comfortable extend
without actually playing some music in
the background it's not like I can't
present anything without music in the
background it's just that when I'm
talking to myself to a microphone to
just a screen and follow me where some
things are happening I just want to have
a soundtrack and I'm beginning to get a
bit of an hypothesis that these
soundtracks actually influence the way
that I do my commentaries which might
also be in the state of mind that I am
in at the moment but at the moment I'm
listening to the thieving magpie from
Clockwork Orange in it is horosho
so um maybe I'll see that making a
commentary in any case it is mainly
foliage work in this episode which is
really for a couple of reasons I usually
like to do and this is something that I
really can not stress enough no matter
what sort of way you want to build your
Park be sure to do it in a way that
you're comfortable with and always build
things that you feel like building and
this does not count to that this does
not count just for the things that you
build but also the order that you build
it in for something for an example um I
sometimes item it that was a word um in
any case sometimes I really feel like I
have a day where I just want to do
foliage I don't really feel like doing
building buildings as much or paths and
really just have that sort of day
foliage work is something that I'm most
interested in and I would say just go
for whatever works best for the sort of
mood that you are in at that point which
is also why this tune into a bit of a
foliage episode since I want to do that
also on a side note this is supposed to
be a transfer trike what I do have to
add about that is that I do not have
much prior knowledge about the way
that's transfer trikes are supposed to
work and I probably done goofed in how
this transfer track is actually looking
over here I don't think it's too much of
a very realistic transfer track another
thing is I've been looking at real
transfer tracks but couldn't really
figure out what I should do so I don't
want to force anybody to comment but I
do think it would be a very nice sort of
theme that if you do leave any sort of
suggestions because this is really
something where I feel like I do not
have certain expertise or knowledge that
I should really have in order to make a
transfer to occur the way that I might
really want to do it if I want to go for
a realistic trying to track then by all
means leave a comment saying no silver
at what you were doing over here is just
complete and utter garbage if you are
going to make a transfer to a controller
cause you can through you should do it
this way with these custom scenery sets
so at the moment and I said it again but
at the moment I feel like this transfer
track is decent it looks like it could
be a functional transfer trikes order
from a distance but really when you get
close to it it is just a bunch of steel
plates then again the question is
whether it actually matters I know
people are too interested in actually
getting transfer trikes to be completely
realistic so that's a bit of a point
that I'll leave of the comments I can't
really tell and this is something that
goes for all of the criticism or
feedback or suggestions that I get I
can't say that I will follow all the
suggestions I can't promise that I'll
try them all or it can get them or in my
park but overall I do have to say that
getting feedback and others shelling
that sharing their knowledge about
certain things that I trying to build is
always very helpful so if you do have
any ideas whatsoever about the trends
like then by all means you can share
them and I might listen to them and
actually finu outs oh wait that is
actually how it should do it so that was
that point then there was the bit that I
wanted to do this staircase on the
backside this is by the way going to be
the cue I just didn't want to do the
rest of the cue because I didn't have
too much of an idea yet as to what I
wanted to do with the cue itself not to
mention that I'm not too great and cute
but that is definitely something that I
will not only build it in the next
episode but also talk about in the next
episode so really the main sort of thing
that gets done in this episode is the
transferor trek which is a bit iffy and
some very basic foliage which is as
always and I also can't stress this
enough it's going to be very simple
foliage and it is quite a formulaic
approach which you may notice if you
watch many of my foliage videos that I
often do things in very similar ways is
that most of the groundwork is done by
the beach cross sets which is known as
the beach one-cent but it's actually PB
and J's Beach fence
I actually got many comments about this
this grass right here is PB and J's
Beach fence it is called Beach fence but
it has grass in it and the cross is
amazing and nobody uses the beach fence
so that's basically about that set but
one thing that I do really have to say
about that set is that I see many people
use this as ground foliage and I would
opt against this which might seem very
contradictive see now I use it quite
often in many of the things that I build
but a very important thing to understand
about the way that this set usually
works in coaches and parks that people
build is that in its most common use the
beach fans cross is actually used as a
foliage blender so you don't use it as
foliage on its own you use it to kind of
get your very low shrubs and you're very
shrubbler areas and kind of connect them
together by just having some very very
subtle grass here and there just to make
the overall thing look a tiny bit better
but you don't use it actually as ground
foliage or any sort of other foliage
that should really cover the area so
that's one thing that I really want to
make clear don't use beach grass sets on
its own just get it to blend and mix it
with other
foliage but on its own it won't work as
well another thing is that the tree
lines which you just saw happen is right
here it's happening as well when I
usually get old Spice's trees because
they are quite low poly and also have a
very good texture and you lower them
onto the ground which makes sure that if
you place a really big row of trees like
that you can't see behind those trees so
you can't see the endless plains of
rollercoaster tycoon 3 sandbox which is
what I don't want people to see because
it's very immersion braking and why I do
this is because it's easy and that makes
sense it saves a lot of time but it also
saves Poly's and it saves your computer
you don't want to feel you don't want to
fill fields of your park map with
foliage it will absolutely destroy your
computer so watch out for that but also
be sure that if you use this technique
of making a large tree line using very
similar trees that you make sure that
you have a row in front of it with more
detailed footage that kind of disguise
is the very simplistic formulaic tree
line which blocks of the view of the
endless plains of rollercoaster country
and make it a tiny bit nicer with some
more fancy and detailed footage at least
that's how I usually do it they're more
about that in my photos tutorial but
this I think would be a very good
example of how it really works when I
time-lapse it and you can really kind of
see it happening that I add the tree
line and then afterwards add the details
around that I can't really add to I
think that is by far the best way to do
it if you already have some foliage you
can add a tree line behind it to make
sure that you don't see the endless
Plains but usually I go for the order
tree line first because it also gives
you a very nice template or way of when
you of where you are going to have your
foliage so that's basically why I kind
of do it like that and the rest of this
is basically going to be a tiny bit of a
flowerbed over here just wanted to fill
the area in front of this train station
a tiny bit and make it look a tiny bit
nicer so that's what's going down over
here the only thing that I am not too
sure about in this area is something
that has been mentioned before is the
fact that these are these are two train
stations in very
proximity and it does look a bit weird
so I might want to look at that in the
future but for the moment I think it
does look alrights as weird as it is to
have two train stations this close to
each other in any case I'm running out
of time and it is about time to end this
episode so thank you all for watching
and I'll see you on the next episode
good